he was the comedy Booker on Conan he
kept whispering in Conan's ear like I
think the speed homes guy would be good
to host this a late night show right
because he wanted a protege or he just
wanted to give a kid a shot I I can't
know another man's mind and you were you
were kind of friendly with Conan at this
point on the show Once and they were
already Whispering Your Praises well
that's they wanted someone unknown they
didn't want it wasn't right they didn't
want the Wayne Brady show they wanted
like who the [ __ ] is this guy which
believe it or not that's what it was
when Conan was on literally like all
caps who the [ __ ] is this guy that's
when he when he first did the Conan
O'Brien show back in the 90s I was a
regular recurring sketch comedy guy oh
wow and I did the Amsterdam kids two
kids who were misinformed about
Amsterdam's liberal social policies and
I did like seven episodes I have them on
tape still and you get paid a couple
hundred bucks and go on and nobody was
watching Conan nobody knew Conan yeah
they were waiting for it to go away yeah
and by today's standards it would have